ils étaient environ une centaine à sept
inscrits pour pouvoir échanger et poser
leurs questions à marlène schiappa et
jean-noël barrot ça faisait un moment
qu'on voulait que marlène schiappa
puisse venir à la rencontre des îles vie
noise et des yvelinois de la 2e
circonscription pour échanger sur les
sujets dont elle a la responsabilité
c'est à dire les sujets de citoyenneté
de laïcité et sur les sujets sur
lesquels elle a eu des responsabilités
par le passé notamment la question de
l'égalité femmes-hommes donc on est on
est très content que cet échange ait pu
avoir lieu plusieurs thématiques autour
de la citoyenneté ont été abordés au
cours de cette réunion publique lundi 15
novembre à vélizy-villacoublay des
sujets comme la laïcité l'intégration
des réfugiés l'abstention ou encore la
protection des femmes face aux violences
fig lassant de voir par-dessus policiers
gendarmes et psychologues
l'heure était aussi au bilan pour la
ministre qui a défendu un grand nombre
de réformes et d'action porté par le
gouvernement des manuels macron depuis
le début de son quinquennat à cinq mois
de l'élection présidentielle et donc
marlène schiappa sur la question de
l'accueil des afghans sur la question de
la lutte contre le séparatisme la lutte
contre les stupéfiants a pu rendre
compte de l'activité des activités de
son ministère et je trouve que c'est
très bien il s'agissait de la première
réunion publique organisée par le député
suite à la crise sanitaire mais
l'objectif est d'en tenir une tous les
mois